hey you guys
it's the flickers of fear show and on
this one doing something a little
different we're doing
a request and this is a movie i had
legit
never ever heard of so i'm really glad
that it was uh brought to my attention
because this was like a really cool
weird ass movie from the 1970s and it's
called the shout
from 1978. now supporter and friend of
the show
rob levinson who was also a filmmaker so
please go and check his stuff out
he actually sent me a link to this film
which you can watch for free on youtube
or at least you could uh this recording
i think you can also watch it on the
british film institute
uh website as far as i'm aware because i
think mark carmoda talked a little bit
about it as well
this movie it's i'm just like amazed i
never heard of it because
like i said and i've said this many
times on the show before but
probably you know if somebody put a gun
in my head and said that i had to pick a
favorite decade for
horror movies it would probably be the
70s and mostly that's just because
they had a real vibe to them and also
some of them were just like so
weird and like off the wall i mean there
was just so much interesting [ __ ] going
on
in the 70s and i just keep stumbling
across
all of these movies that were made back
then that
i had never heard of before so it's just
kind of like the whole decade was just
kind of an embarrassment of britches
and i'm really really surprised that i
had never heard about this one because
it's um it actually did quite well i
think it got uh in the
1978 or 1979 i think it got the grand
jury prize uh
the cannes film festival and it has some
pretty big like uh british stalwart
actors in it
uh alan bates is in there who was also
well he was in a ton of stuff but
um he was in zorba the greek he was
in women in love the ken russell movie
you know among many many many other
things this also has john hurt
in a starring role susannah york also
has a very young tim curry
in a small role and interestingly a very
very young
jim broadbent was in this as dude who
falls in a cow pie
like while he's playing cricket so
there's that as well i didn't even
recognize him actually
so this movie it's set in the uk it's
set in england
uh and it was shot in devon i believe
and it's from
a short story that came out in the 1920s
either 1924 or 1926 i couldn't like uh
get a handle on that
by robert graves who was a british
writer
however the director of this is a polish
director
jerzy scolomovsky and he uh did a bunch
of
movies i believe in the 70s and 80s that
were set in
britain he did one called moonlighting
he did one called dead end
or deep end rather and uh notably also
he was the co-writer on roman polanski's
first
film knife in the water back in the 60s
and he was kind of known for doing these
sort of weird like art house type of
movies
and this one is kind of like that too
but
oh this it was just so weird i just
loved loved the vibe of this and i just
love the concept of it because it's just
so bizarre and off the wall
and like i said this is one of those
weird things that like you saw in the
70s and really
not any other decade i mean there was
really something about the 70s i don't
know what it was
this movie reminds me of
i don't know like maybe i'm totally
crazy with this but it gave me
a picnic it hanging rock sort of vibe
the peter weir movie
uh it reminded me also of robert
altman's images which also had suzanna
york in it now that i'm thinking about
it
had a little bit of the wicker man and
it almost had a little bit
i don't know what's not exactly like the
william friedkin movie uh the ninth
configuration which was also weirdest
[ __ ]
they're not really that similar but they
kind of like they gave me the same kind
of
feeling about it i don't really know if
i can explain it better than that
but so if you like those four movies
then you probably should like
try and seek this one out because it'll
probably be right up your alley because
it's like this
movie is like weird as [ __ ] and as far
as i know i haven't read the short story
that it's based on but i did read a
pretty like in-depth synopsis of it
and it seems like this was a
pretty faithful adaptation of the short
story
so let me see if i can uh explain what's
going on
so at the beginning it's like it's a
story within a story so you have like a
frame story at the beginning
the frame story is that there's a
cricket match
and it's like the local townsfolk
playing against the inmates
of an insane asylum so they're all like
playing this qriket match
now tim curry's character who's playing
a character called robert graves
who if you'll remember is the name of
the real guy that wrote the story
that this movie was based on so he's
playing that character i don't think
he's an inmate at this time he just came
there like to help out with the qriket
match or something from what i could
determine
so he's there to be a scorer for the
qriket match
and he's in the little booth you know
forgive me british people i really don't
know much of anything about cricket
like i kind of get the gist of it but i
don't know any of the lingo or
anything like that so forgive me if i
like really mess something up because
most of the time i'm like playing i'm
like how the [ __ ] do you even play this
game i don't know but yeah so
apparently there's two scorers and tim
curry's character whose name is robert
graves like i said is one
of them and then he's in the little
scoring booth or whatever it is
with this other creepy dude played by
alan bates
and this guy's name is charles crossley
and while they're talking crossley who
is very kind of a little weird and very
very intense
he's basically like i'm gonna tell you a
story and every bit of it is true
it's like can i you know tell you the
story will you still be able to score
like well i'm telling it to you and you
know tim curry's like
sure man whatever so most of the movies
so that's kind of like the frame story
that there's like a bunch of
people playing cricket some of whom are
uh insane asylum
inmates and then there's these two guys
in this thing and he's telling about a
story it's something that happened
before so it's like kind of a flashback
so the story that he tells
is quite a doozy basically there's a
dude
named anthony played by john hurt
and him and his wife uh who's played by
susannah york
they kind of live this idyllic you know
like english countryside sort of
existence or whatever
now it's implied actually i don't even
know if i'd say implied it's pretty
obvious
that uh john hurt's character anthony is
[ __ ] around
with the wife of i think he's like the
shoemaker or the cobbler or whatever
like in the village
now anthony is a musician
he plays the church organ like for the
services and stuff
and he also seems like he's like an
experimental musician because he's
always
at first like when i they showed him
like in his studio i thought he was like
a foley artist
because he's um you know he's doing
stuff that like foley artists would do
like hey i'm gonna like
have a tray full of marbles and put
water in it like roll in front of a
microphone
and stuff but i guess he's supposed to
be like an experimental musician so
that's what he does kind of on the side
he's also real into uh francis bacon the
painter so there's like a lot of uh
francis bacon type of imagery in this
well not just type of imagery but there
are
he has like francis bacon you know
pictures and stuff like of his paintings
like on the wall and stuff so like i say
you can kind of see what what vibe this
movie's giving off
so he's at uh he you know he comes back
from the church service one day where
he's been playing the organ
now alan bates as crossley
has surreptitiously let the air out of
anthony's tires like on his bike
so that when anthony is there trying to
fix the bike so he can go back home
crossley is basically like use that for
destruction so he could sit there
and kind of talk to him and he really
kind of gets up in his [ __ ] and he's
like talking about what did you think
about that sermon
and he's kind of talking about sort of
you know religious-y kind of stuff and
then basically he very cheekily
invites himself to lunch he's like oh
i'm on a walking tour i haven't eaten in
two days blah blah blah
so it's almost hit this and he's being
kind of like not
not aggressive aggressive but he's being
like real pushy and anthony's
just kind of like okay whatever so he
brings the dude to his house
uh for sunday lunch so you know they
have the
the roast and all that so he sits down
to eat and even though he says he's
really hungry
he only eats like this tiny little
potato or whatever and
you you know that he's up to something
sketchy not only because he's
saying really weird [ __ ] and acting
really weird and creepy
but they tell him like he wants to wash
his hands like he smushes
a fly with his finger like on the window
and then
he goes he asks to go to the bathroom so
you can wash his hands and then he's
kind of like
farting around in their house like he
goes in the spare room and like
tears the um like the duvet off and
he's like sticking his face into suzanne
york's like pantyhose and it's like so
he's doing like weird [ __ ] like that
so then he comes back down they're all
eating it's super awkward
and then he starts saying that he lived
in the australian outback for 18 years
and that he had an aboriginal wife
and he basically says that he killed
all his children and they said like but
that was okay
like it was legal and he has like this
big long and then he starts talking
about
how he learned essentially like
aboriginal
magic like black magic so he can do all
this stuff now i should note too
that before they even met this dude like
before anthony even met this dude
outside of the church
like him and suzanne york were like they
were out on the
dunes or whatever and they had both
fallen asleep
and they both had the same dream about
this dude in like a top coat like a tail
coat
coming toward them like pointing a bone
at them or something like that so they
both have the same dream
so you know that this guy has like some
supernatural [ __ ] going on so at first
you kind of think
like is this dude nuts like he says that
he can do all this like he can do all
this black magic and he talks about like
pointing the bone at people and making
them die
and then he says and this is why the
movie is called the shout
he says that he learned to do and it
took him a really long time but he
learned to do this thing called like the
desolate shout i think it's called
where basically it's just this noise
that you make and it'll everyone that
hears it will drop dead
so anthony obviously does not believe
this but he is intrigued because like i
said he's an experimental musician
so he's like oh i'd be really interested
to hear that um you know because he
doesn't really believe him obviously
because if somebody told you that like
you totally would not believe it
so you know crossley is yet like yeah
but you would die
so they work out this thing where he
kind of like plugs his ears
somewhat or whatever so then they go out
to the dunes he's like we'll go way out
to the dunes like early in the morning
when no one else is around because i
don't want to like you know accidentally
kill people with my
magical shout voice you know what i mean
so they go out to do it and it's like
and he does it and it's this crazy
[ __ ] like
primal like [ __ ] it sounds like i
don't even know like it sounds like a
[ __ ] jet taken off or something like
that it's crazy
so he goes up there and he does it and
it works
meaning it doesn't kill uh anthony like
he but it
for sure like knocks him out and then
you see
like later that it has killed some other
people like it killed like the shepherd
and his sheep and stuff like that so
there's like dead animals like all
around and whatnot
so it's just like this crazy [ __ ] but
then but then anthony turns up like in
bed
later and he's still okay and then the
dog is okay
like because they took the dog with him
and it looked like the dog got killed
also by the voice
the thing about so crossley apparently
this might be an unreliable narrator
situation because it's left kind of
ambiguous
because it's crossly telling this story
to robert graves or tim curry's
character in the present
and crossley is in the asylum he's like
an inmate there
so you're not really sure if he's just
talking about this
like he's just making it up because he's
a nut or
if this [ __ ] really happened because
when he's talking about the story in the
past like
you know when he does the shout it
really does work
so you're not really like i said it's a
weird [ __ ] movie it's like really
really weird
so what he does so apparently he has
not only the power to kill people just
by shouting
but he also if he has a possession of
yours because at one point he takes
uh susanna york's uh buckle like off her
sandal
and he buries it somewhere and so he is
like
has control of her now so basically he
makes her
fall in love with him and so much so
that she's just kind of following him
around everywhere
and it's like anthony comes back to the
house and crossley's there and he's like
oh well i'm taking your wife rachel to
bed and there's nothing you can do about
it he's like what the [ __ ] and she's
just like
yeah that's how it goes man you know
what i mean so it's just like so he's
basically like taking over
like he he can use black magic to
control people
you know what i mean he can like tell
them what to do
he doesn't really seem to have a
motivation for this or reason for this
it's just he's just telling this story
like i just randomly targeted
this couple just because i don't really
know like there's no intention
like i mean there's no uh reason for him
to target them in particular or not
that's uh
revealed anyway so he basically just
insinuates himself like yeah i'm gonna
stay in your house for a few
months and you do and like they have to
do
what he tells them to do because he has
like black magic power over them but as
it goes on
it ends up that finally anthony comes to
the realization of what's going on
and he goes to the dune where he and his
wife rachel who's played by suzanne new
york i know i called her susan at york
like all the time but her name's rachel
in the movie
so he goes to the dune where they were
sleeping at the first time and he digs
around
and he finds all the stuff because uh
crossley hasn't just been controlling
them
he's also been controlling because like
when he shouted like a lot of people in
the village like got sick
like some of the people died like out in
the you know they were out in the dunes
and stuff but people in the village like
got
like got really sick or they felt really
weird or whatever i think he was also
controlling
uh the shoemaker the cobbler guy who
they had gone to to like fix
rachel's shoe and so there was all kind
of weird [ __ ] going on so
anthony goes back to the dune and he
digs around and he finds all the stuff
and then he finds this one thing that's
like a rock and from something that
crossley said to him before
he's like oh this is like the source of
crossley's power so he starts to break
it
and then at that point crossley's uh
power starts to dissolve
the cops come to get him for the kids
that he killed like i said he
said that he killed his own children so
the cops came and then he starts
shouting and like people start dropping
dead it's this crazy [ __ ] story
and then it jumps back to the present
day like on the cricket field
and it's it started to rain really hard
all the insane asylum people are like
flipping out because
you know like stripping their clothes
off and screaming and whatever and it's
just like this chaos
so you don't really know like it does
seem like
so crossley is like freaking out and
he's like i'm getting ready to like
shout or whatever
and at this point like tim curry's
character is kind of like you know don't
because
now he kind of believes it but what ends
up happening is that lightning
strikes the scorers uh little building
there
and ends up killing crossley before
he can shout so you never really knew if
his shout actually could kill people or
if he's just a crazy person
that just thought that because i should
note that two of the
inmates at the asylum who were playing
the qriket game were
john hurt and suzanne york so
you're led to believe that if this [ __ ]
really happened
then the the craziness of what happened
like ended up with both of them
being put into the asylum
but it could just be that crossley is a
nut and he's just making up this story
about them
for whatever reason so like i said if
that description of it
sounds like it's it's a weird weird
movie and it's like really really
it just had this really cool like
unsettling
you know kind of vibe to it it's kind of
like there was
there was even bits where like a little
bit was like slow motion
i will say that i think the best thing
about this i mean other than the acting
which is great
but the best thing about this is the
sound design and that's like what a lot
of people because like i said it's kind
of about
you know the movie being about this guy
that can shout and kill people and the
character of anthony being
a musician and being an experimental you
know doing sound effects and stuff like
that
i should note that there's like two guys
uh what's their names tony
banks and mike rutherford from genesis
uh they did a lot of the music and uh
sound design for this so it's really
like a
cool so if you really if you like
there's not a lot of them but it's like
a kind of a sub
genre of horror movies that are sort of
based around
sound then this is probably one you want
to check out because i'm not saying that
that's that's not like the overriding
i mean there's a bunch of other [ __ ]
going on too because crossley doesn't
just have
the you know the shout that kills thing
but he can also like just control people
by just like telling
them what to do because he has uh you
know an object of theirs that he
is able to like put a spell on and he
can like control you
so he has other things going on too but
what you know one of the main threads
that runs through this is
the power of sound uh you know
so the sound design is like really
really cool and i think that's one of
the things that makes it so
creepy because i think sound is kind of
an underrated uh
aspect of a lot of horror films i mean
if you want to if you just want to know
you want to prove to yourself that
that's true watch a horror movie with
the sound off
and it is instantly not as scary anymore
because it doesn't have any background
sounds or the music or anything like
that
so i really really like movies that
explore that like explore what can be
done with sound and so i think that
this was like kind of really innovative
use of that
and it's really strange because as i
said i had literally never heard of this
movie
um i had never heard anybody talk about
it it's like once
uh rob showed it to me and i watched it
and i was like wow man this movie is
like so
it's so cool and it's so weird and it's
like nobody ever talks about it
i went around and i did find a few
reviews of it like on some horror blogs
and stuff
because this is i would call this a
horror movie but like i said it's a
psychological horror movie in the same
vein as picnic at hanging rock that kind
of stuff
where it's kind of like these
psychological horror movies
you know you could argue that they
aren't horror movies but they're really
kind of like
unnerving they just have this unnerving
vibe to them
and this one i think definitely maybe
even more than picnic at hanging rock
has more of a
you know more of a claim i guess to
being a horror movie because it does
actually involve
black magic or at least somebody
thinking that they have black magic
powers
so i think that pretty much qualifies
but yeah as i said um
thank you very much to rob levinson for
sending me the link to this because
it's it's rare to like for somebody to
come up with a movie
that i haven't seen or at least heard of
and this is one that i never seen or
heard of even though i really really
like
uh british cinema i really like british
horror movies from this era and earlier
so i'm really shocked that i had never
seen it especially since it has um
so many big stars in it and uh so
yeah so thank you very much rob for uh
pointing this out to me and asking me to
do a review on it because this one was a
real it's kind of like a hidden gem
you know so as i said it's on uh youtube
for
free you know the quality isn't
fantastic um as far as i know i don't
think it's gotten like
you know remastered or anything like
that maybe if you
um have access to the british film
institute of the bfi or whatever
website and you can watch it it might
there might be a remastered version on
there i'm not real sure
i don't know really how to go about
watching that i saw the mark carmode
introduction
of it because that was on youtube so i
watched that that's only a couple of
minutes long
where he was kind of talking about it
but yeah so this is definitely
definitely one that if you
like weird 70s cinema like i said if you
like picnic and hanging rock images
um sort of wicker manny sort of in the
sense that
it's uh supernatural elements perhaps
introduced into you know the idyllic
english countryside
type of thing that's how it's similar to
the wicker man but if you like movies
like that
then definitely definitely check this
one out because i feel like
i had never heard of it and i know
probably a lot of other people haven't
either so yeah definitely check it out
and again thanks rob for
bringing it to my attention because i
probably would never have seen it
otherwise
and i really really dug it so that'll do
it for this flickers of fear and i will
see you guys on the next one
bye